[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: So, all
right, so let's start
talking about some math.
So there was a last
result I was going
to prove for series, which is
that if you have an absolutely
convergent series,
and you rearrange it,
then that series
is also absolutely
convergent and converges
to the same thing
as the unarranged series.
But I'm going to leave
that to the lecture notes,
and we're just going to
start on a new topic.
So the topic that we're now
on is continuous functions.
And so continuous
functions, as we'll see,
is a statement about
how a function behaves
near a point in relation to
how it behaves at the point.
Now, what it means
for a function
to behave near a point--
that's the notion
of the limit of
the function, which
is what we'll first discuss.
OK?
Now, at what points are
we going to be looking at?
So this is where
limits take place.
And somehow, we want to look
at a function near points
where there's a set nearby
to actually look at f at.
So f is usually
defined on some set S,
and we want to look at points so
that there's a lot of S nearby.
And we kind of already dealt
with these types of points
when we encountered cluster
points in the assignment.
So this is exactly where
we start looking at limits.
So this is a
definition that I'll
recall from the assignment.
Let S be a subset
of R and x and R.
We say x is a cluster point of
S if, for all delta positive,
the interval x minus delta,
x plus delta intersect
S take away x is non-empty, OK?
So the new
terminology-- not so new
since we dealt with
it in the assignment--
is that of a cluster point.
And another way to
say this is that--
so an equivalent
way of stating this
is that, for all delta positive,
there exists, let's say,
a y in S such that 0 is
bigger than x minus y
is less than delta, OK?
So what this means is that,
as far as the picture goes,
x is a cluster point
if, when I ever
take any small
interval about it,
I can find some S in there
other than possibly x.
And this should be able to
be done for every interval.
So let's take a look
at some examples.
Let's say we take S to be
1/n in a natural number, OK?
And so since now I actually
have people in front of me,
I can actually ask questions.
So whoever first says
it, what would be
a cluster point of this set S?
So what would be a point
in the real numbers
So that there's a
lot of S near it?
Feel free to blurt it
out if it comes to you.
Why don't you just take a guess?
1?
So that's one possibility.
So there has to be a lot of
S near this proposed cluster
point.
So let me mark out the
points that we have.
There's a-- I'll
put 0, and then 1/2
is there, and then 1/3, 1/4,
1/5, 1/6, so on, and so on.
And so I see a guess of 0.
So that's a good guess as well.
So why would 1 maybe
not be a cluster point?
Well, it's because if I draw
a little interval around 1,
then there's only one
point in S in here,
and it's the proposed
cluster point, 1, OK?
So remember, what we
should be able to do
is find in every small
interval [? sum ?] of S
in the interval that's not
equal to the point, OK?
And we can't do that
for the point 1.
But for 0, if we draw
any interval around 0,
there's plenty of S in the
interval not equal to 0, OK?
So here, 0 is a cluster
point of S. And let's
give a quick proof of this.
So we have to verify for every
delta positive this interval, 0
minus delta, 0 plus delta
intersect S take away 0
is non-empty.
So the delta would be positive,
and now here's the picture.
Here's 0.
Here's delta, minus delta.
We have to show that
there's some S in here.
So we simply choose
natural number n
large enough so
that 1/n is there,
and we can always
do this because
of the Archimedean property
of the real numbers, right?
So let delta be positive.
Choose natural number n so
that 1/n is less than delta,
and it's certainly
bigger than 0.
So then n is a natural number.
Then 1/n is in x minus
delta, x plus delta intersect
S take away 0.
So this should
have been 0, which
implies this set is non-empty
because it has something in it,
OK?
All right, was that example OK?
Did you all get that all right?
OK, so feel free to ask
questions as they come up.
So let's do another example.
This one, I will not
give a full proof of,
but we'll just kind of
talk our way through it.
Let's say S is now the
open interval 0, 1.
What is the set of cluster
points of 0, 1 equal to?
So what would be a reasonable
guess or any guess?
Yeah, so, certainly, this will
contain 0, 1, right, since--
so 0, 1, everything
between 0 and 1
should be a cluster
point of 0 and 1
because there's always
a lot of numbers.
I mean, there's a lot of
numbers between 0 and 1.
So if I draw this 0, 1,
and [? have ?] everything
in between 0 and 1 is
certainly a cluster point.
What about the point 1?
Is that a cluster
point of this set?
That's a good observation that,
yeah, it's a sup of the set.
So for every-- right, so
for every delta positive,
if I draw a little
interval around 1,
there's going to be
a number less than 1
that's bigger than 1
minus delta, right?
The set of cluster points
of the open interval 0, 1
is the closed interval 0, 1.
OK?
Now, let's do another example.
Let's say we look at now,
instead of rational numbers--
so you should, again,
think of cluster points
as being the set of points
where there is a lot of this set
nearby, OK?
Now, what is the set of cluster
points of the rational numbers?
OK, so perhaps it will contain
the irrational numbers.
So let's think about
this for a little bit.
So, for example, let's look
at square root of 2, OK?
Perfectly good rational number--
I mean, irrational number.
If I draw a little interval
around square root of 2,
can I find a rational
number in there
that's not equal to
a square root of 2?
Right, because we
have this theorem
about the density of the
rational numbers, right,
that we have--
so remember that this was a
theorem we proved at one point.
For all x, y real numbers
with x less than y,
there exists a
rational number r such
that x is less than r
is less than y, right?
So we can always find
a rational number here,
or we could have taken another
rational number here, yeah?
So for every interval we
draw around square root of 2,
we can find a rational in there
not equal to square root of 2,
obviously.
But we can find a rational
in that interval, yeah?
So this suggests that
the set of cluster points
contains the set of irrationals.
What about rational numbers?
Are those also cluster points?
Let's say I take 0.
Now I look at a small
interval around 0.
Can I find a rational number
in there other than 0?
I'm not asking like,
actually give me one.
I'm just saying, does there
exist a rational number
in this interval other than 0?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: By
this theorem, right?
You can also use
the theorem to find
irrational in this
interval as well.
So no matter if it's square root
of 2 or any irrational number,
no matter if it's
a rational number,
everything is a cluster point.
So the set of cluster points of
rational numbers is equal to R,
OK?
Is that clear?
OK, feel free to stop me
if you have any questions.
So now let's look
at, for example,
S equal to just a
single guy, say, 0, OK?
Remember, cluster
points of a set
means there's a lot
of that set nearby.
Now, I claim that this
guy has no cluster
points because if you think
so intuitively why is this,
this is because, for something
to be a cluster point,
it has to have a lot of
the set near it, a lot.
And there's not a lot
of set to begin with.
There's just one element.
So let's see why
this is the case, OK?
And this gives us
a chance to negate
the definition of cluster point,
which is always a good idea.
OK, so S equals just
the singleton set, 0.
This has no cluster
points, and so the negation
of the definition
of a cluster point--
so x is not a cluster point
of S means if this is some bad
delta--
remember, so the definition of
cluster point is for all delta.
So negation means there
exists one bad delta
so that x minus delta
0, x plus delta 0
intersect S take away x
equals the empty set, OK?
So the picture that
goes along with this
is that x does not
cluster point if there's
some interval and
possibly the only S there
is the point x, but
nothing else, OK?
All right, so let's use the
negation of this definition
to show that there are
no cluster points, OK?
And we have to deal
with two cases.
I want to show x is in R, and
x is not a cluster point of S.
And I'll just do the
case x not equal to 0.
x equal to 0 is much easier, so
we'll just do x not equal to 0.
Let's prove this.
And what's the idea?
We have to be able to find--
so here's 0.
This is all that S is,
is just this point, 0.
Now we have a point x.
What would be an
interval containing
x that contains none of S?
So x here is just
some nonzero number.
S is what's highlighted.
The interval around x that
doesn't contain any S. So
like a x/2?
3x over 2, meaning delta equals
x/2, at least for this picture,
yeah?
OK, and that's
essentially the proof.
So choose delta 0, and
we'll simplify this further
and suppose x is positive.
For x less than 0,
you choose delta 0
to be the absolute value of x.
But for this one, this
is simple enough--
choose delta 0 to be x/2 and x
minus delta 0, x plus delta 0
is equal to x/2, 3x over 2.
And since 0 is not in
this set, in this set,
[? implies ?] intersect S
take away x equals empty, OK?
So we had to find a delta so
that this interval around x
doesn't contain anything
from S, and we've done that
by choosing delta 0 to be x/2.
OK.
So I could have
done it for just--
so I did it for a set
containing just one element,
showed that this set
has no cluster points.
You can also show that if
it has finitely many points,
it has no cluster points.
And so therefore, any finite
set has no cluster points,
but being a cluster
point has nothing
to do with the cardinality.
So if you see the example
in the notes, which
you can think about, and I'm
not going to go over right here,
but, for example, x equals
z, the set of integers--
this has no cluster points, OK?
So being a cluster point means,
where is this set clustering?
So it has nothing necessarily
to do with the size of the set
but where the set is taking up
space in the real number line.
All right, so with the
definition of cluster points,
let me first state the
theorem that, in fact, you
proved in the assignment, which
is that for cluster points--
let S be a subset of R, and
x is a cluster point of S
if and only if
there exist sequence
xn of the elements of and S take
away x such that xn converges
to x, OK?
And that was in the assignment.
You proved that basically
using the squeeze theorem
in the definition.
All right, so with the
notion of a cluster point,
these are the points
in a set where
we're going to start talking
about how a function behaves
near a point, which is the
notion of a limit of a function
is our next definition.
Let S be a subset of R. And
even though I was referring
to cluster points
earlier as x, we're
now going to switch over to c.
Let c be cluster point of S.
And let f be a function from S
to R, all right?
So you say f of x converges
to L as x goes to c.
So this is the new
terminology here.
So here, L is a real number
if, for every epsilon positive,
there exists delta positive
such that if x is in S,
the absolute value of x
minus c is bigger than 0 less
than delta, then f of x
minus L is less than epsilon.
So let's try and compare
this definition a little bit
to what happens for a sequence.
So for a sequence, the
sequence is getting close to L
as long as we go far
enough out in the sequence,
as long as we look at
terms far enough out.
Now, for limits of functions,
that going far enough
out along the sequence
is replaced by,
as long as we look close
enough to the point c
but not at the point c.
So if you'd like, this
says that if x is near c--
and so this is just an
intuitive interpretation
of what this definition says.
If x is near c, then f of x is
near L. And let me also throw
in here that we're saying that
x is near c but not equal to c.
But for a limit, you don't
look at what happens at f of c.
The function doesn't even
need to be defined there to be
able to define what a limit is.
We just care about what
happens nearby, OK?
So you could have--
the picture you should have
in mind is that here's c,
and maybe f is not even
defined up to there,
but there is f, the graph
of the function f there.
There's L, and as long
as I get very close to c,
I'll be very close
to L, "very close"
being measured within
some strip here, OK?
OK, so this is the notion
of the limit of a function
as we approach a cluster point
of the set S where the function
f is defined.
Just a little bit of notation--
typically write like
we did with sequences
f of x converges to L as f of
x arrow L. And then I'll write,
as x goes to c.
Maybe I won't write
We note this by limit of
f of x equals L as well.
OK, so first question about
limits is, are they unique?
And this is, in
fact, why we require
that c be a cluster point of
S because if we didn't require
c to be a cluster point
of S in this definition,
limits would not be unique.
In fact, you could have
functions converging
to whatever you want because
the definition would then
be vacuous.
But if you don't want to
think about that, that's fine.
It's not a big issue.
But I'm just going to
point out at one point,
we're going to use the fact
that c is a cluster point
to prove the following theorem.
So let c be a cluster point
of S, which is a subset of R.
And let f be a
function from S to R.
If f of x converges
to L1 as x goes to c,
and f of x converges to L2 as
x goes to c, then L1 equals L2,
OK?
So this is what I
mean by uniqueness,
that a function can only have
one limit as it approaches
a point c.
Let me give the proof.
So we're going to
play this game again,
where instead of showing
something as 0 or something is
equal to something
else directly,
we'll give ourselves a little
room and prove the following.
We'll instead show that
while epsilon positive,
L1 minus L2 is
less than epsilon.
So L1 and L2, these are
just two fixed real numbers.
If their absolute value
is less than epsilon
for arbitrary
epsilon, then this is
a number which is smaller
than any positive real number.
That implies that that number
is 0, so L1 equals L2, OK?
Why we give ourselves
a little room
is because, in the definition,
we have a small parameter there
which we hope to use.
So let's prove this.
Let epsilon be positive.
So since f of x converges
to L1, there exists--
so just from the definition,
given some small tolerance,
I can find a little
number delta so
that if I look
inside this interval,
I get mapped to the interval L
plus epsilon, L minus epsilon.
So there exists a
delta 1 positive
such that if x is in S-- and
I'm going to probably keep
forgetting to write
that, but that
should be understood that x is
in the domain of the function
f.
If x minus c is less than
delta 1 and bigger than 0,
then f of x minus L1 is
less than epsilon/2, OK?
And the same thing for L2.
I mean, if f of x
is converging to L2,
then there exists a delta 2 so
that I have the same statement.
So instead, I'm just going to
change this 1 to i, i, i, i.
And here, i equals 1 too.
So since f of x converges to
each of these two numbers, L1
and L2, there exists
a delta 1 and a delta
2 so that if I'm within
this tolerance delta of 1
or delta 2, then f
of x minus delta 1--
L1 or L2 is less than epsilon/2.
Let delta be the minimum
of these two numbers.
Now, since c is a cluster
point of S, in fact,
there does exist an x in
S such that 0 is bigger
than x minus c is less
than delta, all right?
And I'm going to use this
x to compare L1 and L2.
Then since x is in this
interval, or I should say,
since it's--
so remember I had
this, which means
I have this inequality
or i equals 1, 2.
I get f of x, or I
should say, L1 minus L2.
This is equal to if I
add and subtract f of x
and now use the
triangle inequality
and use the inequality that's
in green, the f of x minus L1
is less than epsilon/2.
And same for L2, I get--
equals epsilon, OK?
And that's the end
because remember
we started off with the
absolute value of L1 minus L2.
Are there any
questions about that?
OK, so not the most
exciting theorem
in the world that this
thing that we've defined.
A limit is a unique
thing for function.
But let's start looking
at some examples.
And at one point, we'll
look at the negation
of this definition.
So let's suppose-- so
let's look at the limit
as x goes to c of the
function ax plus b.
And I claim this is
equal to ac plus b, OK?
So here, S is, although
I didn't write it out,
this function ax
plus b, this is--
I'm looking at it
defined on all of R,
and c is a real number, OK?
So we have to verify
this definition.
And since it's
for every epsilon,
there exists something.
The beginning of
every proof, I'll
give you a few points
if you can just say,
let epsilon be positive.
How will we choose delta?
Well, you do
similar computations
as you would if you
were doing epsilon m
arguments for sequences.
So what are after?
We want to find delta so that
x minus c less than delta
and also bigger than 0 implies
f of x, which is ax plus b,
minus ac plus b is
less than epsilon.
So let's start off with
this thing, play with it,
and see if we can find
how to choose delta.
Remember, we don't
solve this inequality.
We want to find
how to choose delta
based on estimating
this thing and trying
to make it less than epsilon.
So f of x minus ac plus
b, absolute value--
this is equal to
if you just plug
in f of x equals ax plus
b, this equals a times x
minus c, which equals absolute
value of a times x minus c.
And now we're in business
because the thing
that we do have control
over is the delta, right?
It is how big x minus c is.
So this is less than absolute
value of a times delta
if x minus c is less than delta.
And remember, the thing
that we want in the end
is the thing in yellow, and
the thing we get to control
is the thing in green.
So if I want the
thing in yellow,
and I have the thing in
green, how do I choose delta?
So in the end, I want
f of x minus ac plus b
to be less than epsilon.
Right now, I'm at the absolute
value of a times delta.
Delta is the thing
I get to play with.
So how do I choose it?
Epsilon to be absolute value--
right?
Because if I choose
delta this way, then x
minus c less than delta implies
that, just by this computation
here, I would get
epsilon in the end, yeah?
So that's kind of the scratch
work that goes into it.
Again, delta's the
thing you get to choose.
You get to choose
based on epsilon.
And so you look f of
x minus ac plus b.
You estimate it to be no
bigger than the absolute value
of a times x minus c, which is
less than the absolute value
of a times delta.
And so if you want that thing
to be less than epsilon,
you should choose,
for example, delta
to be epsilon over the
absolute value of a.
There's not a unique choice.
I could have chosen delta to be
epsilon/2 absolute value of a,
but this is a choice, OK?
So let epsilon be positive.
Choose delta to be epsilon
over absolute value of a.
If x minus c is less
than delta, then--
and when you write
the proof, it's
essentially a rehashing of the
best parts of your computation.
And f of x minus
a times c plus b,
this is equal to absolute
value of a times x minus c.
So if we take f of x and
subtract our proposed limit
ac plus b, we get the
absolute value of a times
absolute value of
x minus c, which
is less than the absolute
value of a times delta, which
equals epsilon since we chose
delta to be epsilon/a, OK?
That's the proof.
Are there any questions?
OK, so let's do another example.
Let's look at the
limit as x goes
to c, a square of the
function square root of x.
And I'm going to show this
is equal to square root of c.
And here, although
I'm not writing it,
S will be, for us, the domain
of the square root, which
is the closed interval 0,
infinity, not including
infinity, of course.
And for what I'm going
to do, c is positive, OK?
You can also do c equal
to 0, but for this proof,
I'm going to do c positive.
All right, so I have to
verify this definition, which
means for every epsilon,
I can find a delta,
so let epsilon be positive.
Let's go over to our box of
scribbling and scratching.
So remember, our goal
is to find a delta which
I can choose so that f of
x minus square root of c,
in this case, is
less than epsilon.
So if I look at f of x
minus square root of c,
this is square root of x
minus square root of c.
And perhaps you remember
from your days in calculus
that whenever you see the
difference of two square roots,
it's a good idea maybe to
multiply the top and bottom,
or, I guess, multiply by
1 in a very special way,
so that I get the
difference of squares.
So this is equal
to the square root
of x minus square root of
c times square root of x
plus square root of c
all over square root of x
plus square root of c, OK?
And so now I have--
on the top, I have product
a minus b times a plus b.
So that's the difference
of squares, which gives me
x minus c on top
over square root of x
plus square root of c, OK?
And remember, this is
less than the thing
that we're going to
choose in the end.
The absolute value of x
minus c is less than delta,
so this is less than square
root of x plus square root of c.
Now, in the end,
you have to only--
you can choose delta
depending only on epsilon
and maybe the point c, OK?
You cannot choose it to be
dependent on the point x,
which is changing, right?
What maybe you're
tempted to do here
is to then choose delta
to be square root of x
plus square root
of c times epsilon.
Don't do that because
delta, again, only
depends on the point c
and the point epsilon.
It cannot depend on the thing
that's changing, which is x,
right?
This is changing.
So you don't make this choice.
Now, if we just
do one more thing,
then we'll get to
something where
we can choose an independent of
the thing that's changing, x.
The square root
of x on the bottom
is only making things smaller
because that's non-negative.
So this is less than or equal
to delta over square root of c,
OK?
So now, in the end, I have
something which is delta
and depends on
the point c, and I
want f of x minus square root
of c to be less than epsilon.
So how should I choose delta?
Shout it if you know it.
Right, epsilon times
the square root of c.
So now this will be our choice.
So choose delta to be epsilon
times square root of c.
Now we have to show this delta
works, which is essentially,
again, just rehashing
our computation
over on the right, which
gave us how to choose delta
than if the absolute value of
x minus c is less than delta,
f of x minus square
root of c-- and I'm not
going to write f of x.
I'm going to write the square
root of x is equal to basically
what we did over here
in the box, which
is absolute value of x minus
c over square root of x
plus square root of c, which
is less than or equal to,
if I take away the square root
of x on the bottom like we did
before, which is less than
delta or square root of c, which
equals epsilon square root of
c over square root of c, which
equals epsilon.
So this delta works.
OK, Is there any questions
about that example?
OK.
So let's do one more example,
which really illustrates what
I was getting at when I was
talking about the limit only
cares about what the function
is doing near a point
but not at the point.
So let's say we look at the
function f of x given by 1,
if x equals 0, and 2,
if x does not equals 0.
So this is-- here's the point 0.
And where it's not equal
to 0, it's equal to 2,
and when x equals 0, it's
equal to 1, all right?
And they claim that the limit
as x goes to 0 of f of x--
this equals 2.
And the thing to
note is that this
limit it does not
equal f of 0, which
it did for the previous
two cases, right?
If we look back at
these two examples
that we did a minute
ago, the limit
as x goes to c of
both of these examples
was I just plug in c
to the function, right?
But for this example,
that's not the case.
The limit is not equal to the
function evaluated at the point
in highlighting
that limits don't
care about the function
evaluated at the point.
They care about what's
happening near the point, OK?
And near the point, f of x is
just equal to 2 identically.
So I'll give you
the quick proof,
or you can completely
ignore it and just
believe that the limit as x goes
to 0 of this function equals 2.
So the point is that for
x not equal to 0, f of x
is just a constant 2.
So let epsilon be positive.
And you can choose
delta to be whatever
you like because f of x
when x is not equal to 0
is going to be equal to
2, the proposed limit.
Then if 0 is bigger than the
absolute value of x minus 0,
which is just x,
is less than delta,
then this implies x
is not equal to 0.
And therefore, if I
look at f of x minus 2,
this is just 2 minus 2 equals 0,
which is less than epsilon, OK?
Any questions
about this example?
No questions?
All right, so what we'll
talk about now is--
so before this section
on continuous functions,
or at least this section
on limits of functions,
we had the notion of
limits of sequences.
And so a natural
question is, how
do limits of functions
and limits of sequences
belong together, interact,
relate to each other, I guess,
is the best way to
phrase that question.
And the point is that to
decide if a function has
a limit it, suffices to stick in
sequences that converge to that
point that you're looking at.
And that's the content
of the next theorem.
So let S be a subset of
R, c cluster point of S.
Let f be a function from S to R.
Then the limit exists.
Limit as x goes to c of f of
x equals a number L. This is
equivalent to the statement
that for every sequence
x sub n of elements
of S take away
c such that xn converges to c,
we have f of xn converges to L,
OK?
So again, the statement
of this theorem
is that a function
converges to L if and only
if for every sequence I
stick into the function which
converges to c, f of x
then converges to L. So
to choose or to decide
if a function converges,
it suffices to
look at convergence
of certain sequences, OK?
OK.
And why is this
theorem important,
or at least very useful?
It's because with this
theorem, we now get basically
every analog of theorems we
proved for sequences for free,
for example, limits of sums
of functions, a squeeze
theorem that can be stated for
limits of functions, and so on.
And I'll say a few
comments about this
after we proved the theorem.
All right, so let's--
this is a two-way street.
And I'm going to mark the
second statement in green.
That way, I don't have
to rewrite it again.
So first, assume that limit at
x goes to c of f of x equals L,
and now we want to prove
the statement in green, OK?
So here's the idea.
So now we want to show--
so let xn be a sequence
of elements in S
take away c such that
x sub n converges to c.
And what we want
to show is that f
of xn, which is
now a new sequence
converges to L as
n goes to infinity.
OK, so here, you
should write, as n
goes to infinity, in here, OK?
So let me move that, and let
me draw the picture of why
you should believe this.
So remember, what it
means for a sequence
to converge to a number
means, for every epsilon,
there exists a capital M
so that for all n bigger
than or equal to capital M, the
sequence is close to the number
L within epsilon distance to it.
So let's think about
this a little bit.
I'm not going to draw the graph.
I'm just going to draw two
copies of the number line.
Here, we have the
number L. Here's
the number c and L plus
epsilon, L minus epsilon.
So let epsilon be positive.
And the idea is we want
to be able to find or say
there exists a natural
number capital M so
that n bigger than or equal
to capital M implies f of xn
is inside this interval here.
Now, since f of x converges
to L as x converges to c,
there exists a delta so that--
so this is the picture
that goes along with it--
so that if I'm inside
this interval here,
then I get mapped into
this interval here.
So this is what I get
from the assumption.
So then how I should choose
the natural number capital
M is so that all
of the x sub n's
lie in this interval, c
minus delta, c plus delta.
And if I can arrange
that, which I can
because the x sub
n's converge to c,
then I will get that
these guys get mapped
into this interval, L plus
epsilon, L minus epsilon, OK?
And that's the whole
idea of the proof.
Now we just need
to write it down.
Since f of x converges to L,
exists a delta positive such
that if less than delta, then if
x minus L is less than epsilon.
That's what I drew
in yellow there.
Now, since the sequence
x sub n equals c,
this implies that there exists
some natural number M sub
0 such that little n bigger
than or equal to M sub 0--
since all of these x sub n's are
not equal to c, by assumption,
they're in the
set S take away c.
X sub n minus c, and absolute
value is bigger than 0
and less than delta, OK?
This follows from the definition
of convergence of sequences
to a point.
Here, if you like,
I'm choosing epsilon
in that definition to be delta.
And this delta is coming
from the definition
for convergence of functions.
And so we'll choose capital
M to be this integer M sub 0.
And if n is bigger
than or equal to M,
I get that, by our choice
of it being M sub 0,
you get that x sub n minus
c is less than delta.
That means that it falls in
this little yellow highlighted
part in the first number
line, which implies--
so here, what I'm using is
what's highlighted in blue.
So this is content
of this implication--
implies that f of xn minus L is
less than epsilon, all right?
And that's what we
wanted to do, right?
We wanted to show that there
exists some natural number
M so that n bigger than or equal
to M implies f of x minus L
is less than epsilon
in absolute value.
And therefore, we've
proved that the limit as n
goes to infinity of the
sequence f of xn equals L.
OK, so that's one direction of
this if-and-only-if statement.
Let's prove the
opposite direction.
So suppose what's
highlighted in green holds.
OK?
And this proof is going
to be by contradiction.
So let's suppose that our
assumption, what's in green,
holds.
But the limit as x goes to c
of f of x does not equal L.
And now we're going to do
the proof by contradiction,
meaning suppose the
outcome is false.
OK?
We're still assuming
what's in green holds.
That's our assumption.
And for proof by
contradiction, we
assume that the outcome
or the conclusion
is false, which is that the
limit as x goes to c of f of x
does not equal L.
Now, what does this mean?
So now we get to
negate the definition
and get better
acquainted with it.
This means that--
so the definition
of limit, if you go back to
the notes is, for all epsilon,
there exists a delta statement.
So the negation is
that there exists
some bad epsilon,
epsilon 0, such
that for all delta positive,
there exists an x such
that x is close to c, but f
of x is far away from L. OK?
So the negation
of the definition
of limit of something
being the limit
is that there
exists a bad epsilon
so that no matter
how close I get to c,
I can find something very close
to c that's far away from L
if I stick it into f, OK?
That's the intuitive way
of viewing the negation
of this definition.
OK, so now I'm
going to apply this
with delta chosen to be 1/n
for in a natural number, OK?
And this says-- so
this statement here
is a for-all-delta statement.
So that holds for
every delta I pick.
So for all n, a natural number,
there exists an x sub n such
that 0 is bigger than x sub n
minus c is less than delta--
I'm going to pick to be 1/n--
and f of x sub n minus L
is bigger than or equal
to epsilon 0.
So first off, I made
a for-all-n statement.
Let's think about this
for just a second.
So certainly, for
delta equals 1,
I can find a number x sub 1
satisfying 0 is less than x
minus c is less than 1, and f
of x minus f of x sub 1 minus
L is bigger than or
equal to epsilon 0.
But delta can be anything I
choose, so for delta equal 1/2,
I can find an x
sub 2 such that x
sub 2 minus c is less than
1/2, and f of x minus L
is bigger than or
equal to epsilon 0.
So I'm just choosing delta
to be 1/n for each n,
a natural number.
Choosing delta to be 1/n, OK?
Is this point clear?
OK, please stop me if you
have questions and something
is not clear.
OK, so I have this
sequence of elements of S
that are not equal
to c because they
are an absolute
value bigger than 0,
or the absolute value of x sub
n minus c is bigger than 0.
And they satisfy these
two inequalities, OK?
Then let me just write
this inequality again.
So then the inequality
that I have is, for all n,
the natural number 0 is
less than x sub n minus c
is less than 1/n.
I claim that the x sub n's
must then converge to c.
What tool can I use to say that?
Squeeze theorem, OK?
Because this thing
on the left, 0--
this, if you like,
is a sequence, just
a constant sequence.
This converges to 0.
And 1/n, something on
the right, converges to 0
as n goes to infinity.
So that implies the
thing that's sandwiched
in between gets squeezed to 0.
So that implies limit as n goes
to infinity of x sub n minus c
equals 0, i.e.,
xn's converge to c.
Now, I'm assuming what's
in green holds, which
is, if I take any sequence
converging to c, f of xn
has to converge to L, OK?
So by what's in green has
given me this implication--
0 must be equal to limit
as n goes to infinity
of f of x sub n minus L.
But What.
I know is that,
since I've assumed
f of x does not converge
to L, along this sequence,
each of these guys is bigger
than or equal to epsilon
0, which is positive.
So now I've concluded
that 0 is bigger than 0.
That's a contradiction, OK?
OK, so next time, we'll
talk about the applications
of this theorem.
Do you all have any questions
about this proof or anything
that we've covered so far today?
You mean how you get the
choice of delta from doing--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CASEY RODRIGUEZ: Right.
So let me phrase this a--
Yeah, I mean, so--
and probably in
most classes, you
would just be given this proof
that's over here on the left.
And somehow it looks
like magic that I
chose this delta this way,
and it ends up working, right?
But the thinking that
goes in behind it is--
so what's the thing you want?
You want what's in yellow.
So let me erase some
of what's in yellow.
You want to choose
delta so that if you
take f of x minus ac plus b,
that thing in absolute value
will be less than epsilon, OK?
So start with that thing
that you want to make small
and that you want to ensure is
small, f of x minus ac plus b,
and start computing.
And when you compute it,
you get what we got here
in the second bit of yellow.
And we're assuming that the
absolute value of x minus c
is less than delta, right?
We're trying to choose
delta so that what's
in green implies
what's in yellow.
So far, we haven't chosen delta.
We just know that the
absolute value of x minus c
will be less than delta.
And we want to choose
delta so that that
implies what's in yellow
after the arrow there.
So when we do this
computation, and assuming
that the absolute value of x
minus c is less than delta,
we get this thing right
here, the absolute value
of a time delta.
This is just assuming that the
absolute value of x minus c
is less than delta, which
is what will it be assuming.
And we want what's in
yellow, which is that thing
to be less than epsilon.
So what we've arrived
at is this thing here,
which we want less
than epsilon, is less
than this thing in red, OK?
And therefore, we want
to choose the delta
so that the thing in
red is less than epsilon
or less than or
equal to epsilon.
That will ensure
that f of x minus ac
plus b in absolute value will
be less than epsilon, OK?
So I'm not solving
an inequality.
I'm not solving the
inequality I want,
which is f of x minus ac plus b.
I'm starting with
what's on the left,
estimating it using my
assumptions, and then,
at the end, choosing
delta so that I come up
with epsilon in the end.
So in the last step,
I have absolute value
of a times delta.
And I want that to
be less than epsilon.
So I could have chosen
delta to be less than
or equal to epsilon/a.
So anything, any delta like
that would have worked.
So I could have put delta
to be epsilon over 2a.
That still would have
worked, or 3a, OK?
Yes, [? what ?]
[? they're ?] green.
That's the thing
we're doing, thing we
get to use in this computation.
Are there any other questions?
This is a style
thing, all right?
So throughout this entire
semester, for all epsilon,
you have to be able to find the
M so that something happens,
right?
So at some point, you
always say, choose
M to be something, right?
Maybe it's the maximum of
some M0, M1 that you had.
Or choose M to be so that 1/M is
less than epsilon or something
like that.
So I'm just sticking with
that style of saying,
choose M to be this.
Otherwise, I could
have said, there
exists a capital number M
so that for all n bigger
than or equal to
capital M, x sub n minus
c is less than delta, and
then move to the next part.
But throughout the course, I've
always, at least in the proofs
I presented, you're making a
choice of capital M, right?
It's for all
epsilon, there exists
a capital M. So that
means you have to tell me
how to choose capital M.
And it's the same thing
with these epsilon
delta proofs is that, for all
epsilon, there exists a delta.
So at some point, you
have to tell me how
to choose delta in the proof.
So I've just kind of
stuck with that style
of saying, choose M to be
something, although you're
absolutely right that
I could have just said,
for all n bigger than
or equal to capital M0,
I have what I want.
And therefore,
implicitly, I'm saying
that M equals M0 is
the thing that works.
Yeah, that's the same delta.
Mhm.